news conference shortly with vice
president Pence and secretary Pompeo
thank you to president Erdogan millions
of lives will be saved
let's bring in patty cohan she's joining
us from Washington and listening to the
vice president speak in Ankara
he seemed to be crediting the ceasefire
to the strong relationship Turkey and
the United States have and also the
strong relationship between the two
presidents Iran and Trump patty talk us
through what came the what you heard
during that press conference out of
Ankara yeah there is a whole lot to
unpack here so let's take a look at what
the Vice President is saying he is
saying that Turkey has agreed to stop
its offensive because it's going to get
exactly what it wanted to get they're
going to get the safe zone allegedly
according to Mike Pence the question is
and he kept saying well the it's
happening now the YPG the SDF they're
moving we're helping them move one of
the things I'm going to be asking in the
the Pentagon how is that happening
you've already admitted that the troops
have the US troops have moved out of
there going so far as to blow up their
bunkers and their ammunition in a hasty
retreat the other question I have is why
would the YPG listen to the United
States and the vice president actually
said we have a good relationship with
them because we worked with them to
fight ISIL but then they abandon them to
the Kurds so he said that they have an
agreement with those fighters to
basically withdraw from that 32
kilometer area that woman always said
that he wanted stand by for a moment
patty apologies because we're just going
to cross back to Ankara and listen to
what the Turkish Foreign Minister has to
say protecting integral territorial
integrity of the Syria according to
United Nations resolution 54 we
expressed reiterated that our
obligations to this and also we
confirmed our solidarity as a allies YPG
will withdraw within the 120 verse then
we will stop we will
we will not stop the operation yet but
we will put it on a hold because this
fire can only be agreed between two
sovereign states the terrorist
operations were the target of the
operation so we are just putting it on
to hold allow terrorist organizations to
withdraw from the area once they leave
the area and completely withdraw and we
will stop the operation operation USA
will lift sanctions and once we comply
with all the conditions that is within
the 120 hours once the IPG withdrawal is
completed then operation will be stopped
and then current sanctions will be left
at the east of Ephrata s-- we will
cooperate regarding you to our fight
against - and was determined to fight
with - until now and and more than 4000
- neutralized in - members neutralized
and we always reiterated that when
fighting with terrorists organization
there is no need to use any of the
terrorist organizations
they've we agreed to cooperate in fight
against - president's strong leadership
enabled us to reach this resolution and
USA delegations was visiting here and
the from Baku our president held a
telephone conversation and then our
President did say that once the
delegation arrived we can talk about the
issue because Trump was asking for
ceasefire
yesterday we had delegations here and
Defense Minister of Defense and the team
of the minister of defense and
intelligence services and and other team
members from our ministries have been
working in the negotiations and we
support we reach to this resolution I
would like to thank to all if there are
any questions I am happy to answer those
questions minister regarding to secure
secure area will be limited to therapy
up pants used about 20 miles but
previously it was mentioned that 440
kilometer length will it reach to 440
kilometer long as you all know USA
military is withdrawing from this region
including members and in some other
areas regime is present there and border
areas including commish regime is
present there as well and yesterday in
kobani area was also was entered by
regime forces so who are we going to
talk yesterday our president talk to
Putin
on the phone last night talk about the
steps will be taken in Syria and was
invited to Sochi and then we will be
able to discuss all these issues our
objective was 32 premature and from
eastern Euphrates to
yaki border which is 140 kilometers long
in that area objective was the clear
from terrorist and establish secure zone
here this is important for our security
which was emphasized all the time by our
president when he was meeting with
leaders this will displaced people and
refugees will be able to repatriated and
accommoda accommodated in this region
it's 440 kilometer and 32 kilometer
that some parts of this issue will be
discussed with USA and other parts will
be discussed with Russia and then
necessary steps will be taking you're
listening to the Turkish Foreign
Minister speaking from Ankara he was
speaking right after the u.s. vice
president Mike Pence in the secretary
State Mike Pompeo also spoke from the
capital the Turkish Foreign Minister
confirming the suspension of the
offensive that's taking place right now
in the northeast of Syria let's bring in
padico hain once again she's joining us
from Washington Patti because you were
unpacking the US side of the story for
the for us and talking us through what
the US vice president had to say about
the ceasefire so let's go back to that
so let's think about what Turkey wanted
at the onset of this they wanted a free
and clear 32 kilometer deep zone into
Syria and that foreign minister or the
spokesman just there said that the goal
is to repatriate
hundreds of thousands of Syrian refugees
into that area that is exactly what the
SDF the YPG did not want and so let's
think about what the vice president just
said he's basically saying through
five-day ceasefire the turkey is going
to get exactly what it wanted at the
ounce at the onset it's going to get
this safe zone then he went on to say we
have a great relationship with the YPG
because of our long-term fight with them
over against ISIL he didn't say that
basically the u.s. just abandoned them
when it pulled its troops out so
suddenly on the president's tweet so he
said that they are going to move back
now he said they have assurances he said
it's happening right now that the US
military is in fact helping that helping
make that happen
we're going to be asking the Pentagon is
that is in fact true because according
to the Pentagon the US forces that were
there have pulled out and did it in such
a hasty way that in some cases they were
forced to bomb their ammunition so it
wouldn't fall in to Turkish hands not a
very effective method to do it but it
does show just how hasty of a retreat it
was so this is the vice president
putting this the spin on it that this is
all fine and good and the YPG is going
to listen but I think we just heard
again from the spokesman the key player
here is not the vice president it's not
president Trump it's Vladimir Putin and
so he said he's going to go and talk to
Vladimir Putin because the YPG the SDF
they are now aligned with Russia and the
Syrian government so if they're going to
move it's going to be because those
people told them to I don't think the
vice president saying that they have a
great relationship can be taken as
credible given everything that's
happened over the last couple of days
one thing I should point out is the
president just tweeted US President
Donald Trump just tweeted the deal could
never have been made three days ago
there needed to be some quote/unquote
tough love in order to get it done great
for everybody proud of all so again the
president talking about tough love and
one of the things that pence held up is
these sanctions that the president had
put on Turkey these were not exactly
tough sanctions every expert I spoke
with said this isn't really going to
hurt the Turkish economy so pence is
saying but part of this Agreement means
there will not be US sanctions on Turkey
the vice president doesn't get to say
that he doesn't get to decide that the
US Congress is currently talking amongst
themselves in a bipartisan bicameral way
to come up with turkeys sanctions on
Turkey things like cutting off military
aid stopping weapon sales personally
going after people close to Iran if
their finances in the United States we
don't know if this is going to be enough
for Congress because again according to
the vice president Turkey is getting
exactly what Turkey wanted at the onset
of this before the offensive to move the
Kurds out of that safe zone as they keep
calling it so and the Senate Majority
Leader Mitch McConnell he pretty much
sent the message they have the votes
they have enough votes before this
announcement to override any potential
presidential veto so the vice president
can tell the president of Turkey that
there are gonna be any US sanctions but
yet he doesn't get to actually decide
that the US Congress will decide that
all right patty thank you for helping us
unpack that from Washington let's bring
in Zena Hoda she's joining us from act
Akali that's on the turkey-syria border
Dana what then does this actually mean
for the YPG when the vice president says
the withdrawal has is already underway
well the YPG which is the backbone of
the US allied or what was once the u.s.
allied Syrian democratic forces clearly
they are at the losing end they have
been at the losing end since the United
States decided to withdraw militarily
from the northeast of Syria effectively
ending the protection it had from the US
and patty raising the most important
question why should they listen to the
United States when they already made a
deal with the Russians and by extension
with the Syrian government and in some
front lines in the northeast of Syria
they are side by side fighting with the
Syrian army and the United States saying
that the withdrawal has begun now the
feeling here is that Turkey has won
turkey has won in this round of
negotiations with the United States
they've had a rocky relationship for
some time now in fact before the
high-level US delegation arrived in
Ankara
relations were damaged and there was
talk about the leaked letter Trump's
leaked letter to president Erdogan the
feeling here was that the Turkish
president was insulted he was threatened
and now this deal what this deal does
really is strengthen turkey's hand in
negotiations with the Russians because
on Tuesday the Turkish president is
supposed to head to Sochi and we know
what Russia wants from Turkey they want
Turkey to end their military presence
all together not just the east of the
Euphrates but across northern Syria
Russian officials repeatedly saying we
believe the Syrian government should be
positioned along the border they wanted
to reactivate the so-called Adana
agreement allowing turkey just to
operate a few kilometers inside Syria
for a counterterrorism operation but not
stay permanently in Syria a better
relationship with the United States and
Turkey is not what Russia wants to see
so now Turkey got what it wanted it said
Oregon made this very very clear
yesterday no ceasefire unless the Syrian
Kurdish armed group which which he
considers our turkey considers a
terrorist organization would draw Surti
kilometers from the border that is now
going to happen according to the United
States now everyone's talking about the
30 kilometers so now we know the depth
but we know the major disagreement
between Turkey and the United States is
the length and the depth of that safe
zone that's why Turkey launched this
operation because they were not in
agreement we heard from the United the
United States made clear that turkey
will not engage in kobani kobani is a
border town it should be included in
that safe zone according to turkeys map
then we heard the Turkish Foreign
Minister say it's 140 kilometers east of
the Euphrates up to the Iraqi border so
we don't have all the details now but
what we can say is this there's a deal
Turkey got what it wanted and definitely
it strengthens its hand but the question
is is Russia involved some way or
another in this deal all right
Xena thank you for that Dana reporting
from AXA Calais let's pick this up
further with Marwan Bashara he's out 2-0
senior political analyst joining us from
London did Turkey get what it wanted
Marwan
yes
not even more so I would say the rain
that what what vice president Pence is
calling a ceasefire it's looking more
and more like a surrender of the Kurdish
forces / the United States to Turkey on
Turkish conditions of I would say but as
Xena said and this is very important it
of course remains to be seen what do we
mean by the safe zone is it the 300 is
it the 32 by 4 3 400 kilometers or is it
150
of course we probably need to look at
the maps in the next 5 days but my
understanding is that the Kurds should
have expected this result long ago yes
as Xena said since the United States
expressed its its intentions to withdraw
but really we've known in this region
for a century now that geography Trump's
strategy and that while the United
States might be involved even Russia but
in the end of the day countries like
turkey or Iran regional powers of this
nature in the end of the day have a lot
of weight and it was clear to the ypd
that there is so much they could do or
resist when turkey finally decided to
move in to northern Syria and the fact
that the United States was puffing and
threatening with sanctions and so on and
so forth and then are they accepted in
principle that turkey has a role to play
in northern Syria and that this is a
safe zone now that's all remember that
turkey also has other strategic goals
through for its incursion to lure Syria
notably blocking the possibility of any
autonomy for the Kurds in North Syria as
well as taking over the PKK and YPD or
whatever mutation they
for Kurdish resistance there so Turkey
has strategic objectives beyond simply
helping Syrian refugees settle in in
North Syria for the time being and
marijuana roots mentioning Russia just a
moment ago to what extent do you believe
that Russia was involved in this I
actually think they were involved in
this and I think Xena was was very you
know wise in saying that there must have
been something for Russia and and
president of the line is going to be
meeting with President Putin and so and
so forth because I don't think this is
going to happen without some sort of a
coordination between the way the Syrian
forces meaning Assad's forces are moving
north under the guidance if you will of
President Putin and the way now Turkey
is moving south with or in coordination
with the United States so here you have
it probably I would guess that Russia
had a role to play in facilitating the
idea that the the Kurds would be pulling
out whether it is to the other part of
northern Syria or elsewhere remains to
be seen but clearly now there's a
there's a global understanding between
Turkey and the United States on the one
hand and I would say Russia as well in
order to make sure that the ceasefire
does hold and that turkey does have a
footing in nor Syria and all of that by
the way the rain is apparently important
also in terms of discussing the future
of Syria meaning anyone now looking at a
long-term settlement for Syria is going
to have to take turkey in consideration
ok Marwan Bashara thank you